oh real [ __ ] imma tell you something
about like guys with humor
you know because in this rap game in
this business everybody wouldn't be
tough everybody wouldn't be shook like
[ __ ] you not tough like relaxed bro
it's a little [ __ ] that's five three
that gotta knock you off bro relax
and i don't want to be like that like
i'm like the cool guy like guys don't
you ever talk like that but right you're
right you're feeling but everybody want
to be tough and [ __ ] and like i hate
that that's one thing i hate about
people bro like everybody especially
people in this culture like mm-hmm it's
like my [ __ ] relax bro
my man's over there blow you
pause and we
and we'll sit right here until the
police come right that's crazy bro just
relax like
just relax
but we but we good are we cool whatever
but it's like that sh i hate that [ __ ]
bro because like
it's the people like your favorite
rapper
your favorite artist don't have no
character and that [ __ ] laying for you